when i'm trying to create a player i'll
be trying to create like a like a
monstar never miss and my physicals
would have to just be like thor or
something you know what i'm saying
i heard across the board if it was
possible all right let's get these
threes up what nba player skill set what
i want the most probably stop with curry
it's like fluid from ball handling to
shooting and he can shoot from anywhere
playing with kevin was fun man it's
insane to see him with his own sneaker
with his own everything you know i mean
commercials that's great company cuzzy
great company
from the metaverse homie see this part
of it is so crazy to me bro this town
looks fire like i want to go there if i
would have had this growing up this
would have had me in the crib my parents
wouldn't have no problem like this is
just insane like you know i'm sure you
can walk through the mall go shopping
[Music]
just skip the line see that that's i
like that oh put that crenshaw hoodie on
you already know what's going on yeah
watch out man i need some sneakers
there's some newer sneakers that's dope
but i'm more into the retro joints blue
drink is looking fun
he never used to see what nba players
was winning besides the jerseys players
dressed today however they want is
actually a part of
the culture now you'd be waiting to see
what sneakers they wearing off the court
the outfits they went off the court
that's super dope too cool for school
has to be fancy forward come on man
why are you walking like that oh
oh he crumping my experience walking on
the runway during new york fashion week
i enjoyed it to be honest with you it
just had me in some funny boots i had
some real funny boots for that journey
at the hospital when i was born my first
little pictures with a basketball head
that was like me and my dad's barn
growing up i was rebellious a lot of
that but if the game coming on we good
basketball was really like my heart for
a long time so when it didn't work
it hurt brick was was somebody that came
into my life and really brought
basketball back to me in an exciting way
and i mean i got a nephew people trained
with him and all that's a great dude
great friend it's just funny how it all
came back full circle now i'm doing nba
2k a bunch of different things that
involve basketball as a rapper gotta
take this hoodie and his hat off that's
why you ain't making that
[Music]
this is stew nah they got smiles in the
game it's like you're watching a tv show
oh they got rhymes on here for you this
is crazy if i like get clouded in my
talents in south beach that one did we
get hyped for anything you're the new
manager man this is so fire though best
rapper in the nba i think damn literally
probably the best he could ride me fire
my advice to anybody aspiring to do
anything is put your time in it i think
for anything to be worthwhile you got to
have a passion for it and then if it is
your passion
give it everything you got